у берліні з великим за неспокій ним відра
волина посил і не напруга в
українсько-російських видно цінах впав на
важливий і уряду frenzy
і прибрати з Росії україну garnet
ервар поважаючи кулі to cook його хлібну
поважають і заткнула сьюзі стратегію
ескалації збоку україни ж у підриві
читаючого збулося і проти обдурив їх
клинків днів з початку підриву опор
ліній електропередач дали за ринку
монтажному вам отримання з кримом та
прильоті в російських лайнерів через
українську територію ти точно вимкни
тривог у Москві то ж видно реакцію
кремінський догляд ми не мого меншого
знову для політичного рішення
конфлікту в Україні і ми вожатий ціни
турбуєшся в серці заводити цьому
процесу бензин у берліні поважають щік і
у музиці скажеш дистанцію ватою пораду
екстремістський dynax натовпі драйву ліній
електропередач хочеш і відразу мід
і на скільки день здати українською
влада європейські лідери та європейські
політики на магате муся виступає і в
ролі посередника за спокій ти про б дві
сторони конфлікту
тому що ніхто не виграє скеля they
all i українська влада муси читку
показати і я до її міхур конфлікту з
відключенням електроенергії краще
контролю його на ситуації 500 khan vs is
the state of снг
тим часом за поведінкою і українських засобів масової інформації
ремонтники україні ролики на кшталт разів
отримала видно лід та одну з ліній
електропередач на ви можу
кримсько-татарських активістів приплив і
ремонт ініціатори блокади вимагають вигляд
влади криму розпад багнет але ти їх не ви
могли тут вільно не обпалити я знаю
вгамовує шині пари каноні ти скажеш про
її вирішити ситуацію вас за ведучим грані
он і хоче і смути на русі та авіценна
розв'язала конфлікт ми йому сама знає та
стильне вирішення проблем ще б у давос
рукою та проспекти видосах ти результату
all з таким бойкоту мені потрібно його нічого
дзвенить і
ти можеш і викликати та агресію
Росії вже надає це за словом йогор
але the early вразлива чиновата вода
діалогу скай і вам треба ще ставити
ми-то чеку з дому до тисяч swear that
is a slide немає грамоті кістки це магате
сервісні прикуті з українцями
політиками та геймплею мах candy man of a
кбр лорда доїде видна робота вже трава
я проти вчених заяв і всього приводу
відсіку а ти не в роті